This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”。可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个声名狼藉的惯犯时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。听听女性朋友们的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听《回首往事》（The Look Back at it）播客。对1979年来说，那对我是个大日子。84年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。还有我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂得如何应对的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一副盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《知难而进》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. There is a lot going on during this decade and we talk about a lot of it on this podcast, heartbreak, grief,
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们将继续剖析二十岁的心理学。在这个十年里发生了很多事情，我们在本播客中讨论了其中的很多内容，心碎、悲伤，
grief, feeling confused about our future, our careers, our friendships, our relationship with, you know, our families, our bodies, ourselves, the state of the world. But what we don't talk about a lot is how to cope. With so much going on, sometimes we can get really wrapped up in our experiences and our emotions. And the only solution that we have is to begin to rely on some pretty unhealthy coping mechanisms. Or we kind of go numb completely and we tune it all out only to really see our emotional and our mental state get worse and worse. But there is, of course, an alternative.
悲伤，对我们的未来、我们的职业、我们的友谊、我们与家人、与我们的身体、与我们自己、与世界现状的关系感到困惑。但我们没有经常讨论的是如何应对。面对如此多的事情，有时我们会真正陷入自己的经历和情绪中。而我们唯一的解决办法就是开始依赖一些相当不健康的应对机制。或者我们完全变得麻木，把一切都屏蔽掉，结果却发现我们的情绪和心理状态越来越糟。但当然，还有另一种选择。
Today, I want to discuss our ways of coping and dealing with whatever it is you have going on your life and our ways of coping in a positive and healthy way. For me, I always see coping mechanisms as like the umbrella in a storm. They shelter us from the worst of the weather in our lives, as cheesy as that sounds. And, you know, the storm doesn't stop. We might still feel a few raindrops. But our coping mechanisms are the thing that shields us. there are so many proactive ways that we can, you know, seriously help ourselves out during tough times or even regular times when things set us back or frustrate us.
今天，我想探讨我们应对生活中的种种事情的方式，以及以积极和健康的方式应对的方法。对我来说，我总是将应对机制比作暴风雨中的雨伞。说得通俗一点，它们为我们遮挡了生活中最恶劣的天气。而且，你知道，暴雨并没有停止。我们可能还是会感觉到几滴雨点。但我们的应对机制就是为我们遮风挡雨的东西。有很多积极的方法可以让我们在艰难时期，甚至是事情让我们受挫或沮丧的平常时期，认真地自救。
And it is so wild to me that in all of our years at school being taught calculus and long division and the history of civilizations that aren't even around anymore, all things that I'm sure are very important. But amongst all of that, we are never really taught how to properly regulate. our emotions and our nervous system. We are never taught effective psychological strategies for managing some of those universal things in our lives, for managing failure or loss or distress. And these are skills that I think everyone could use. I don't think I know everyone could use these. And they are so often neglected or left out of our education or our general knowledge.
让我感到非常疯狂的是，在我们上学的多年里，我们被教导微积分、长除法以及那些甚至早已不存在的文明的历史，所有这些我都确信非常重要。但在所有这一切之中，我们从未真正被教导如何正确调节我们的情绪和神经系统。我们从未被教导过有效的心理策略来管理生活中那些普遍的事情，来管理失败、失落或痛苦。这些我认为每个人都能用上的技能。我不认为，我知道每个人都能用上这些技能。而它们却经常被忽视，被排除在我们的教育或常识之外。
And just personally, I believe that you shouldn't need a psychology degree or years of therapy. to know how to make life work best for you. So today, we are going to break down the psychology of coping mechanisms. We are going to talk about the different categories of coping skills and coping mechanisms that we come across from emotion focus to problem focus to adaptive versus maladaptive. You know, here's the thing, not all coping mechanisms are created equal. There are a whole lot of behaviours that may make us feel better in the moment, but which are super detrimental in the long term. Alcohol is a great example of that. You know, yes, it naturally lowers our levels of anxiety and if that was the only thing that we were concerned with, well, then
仅就我个人而言，我认为你不应该需要心理学学位或多年的治疗，才能知道如何让生活为你发挥最佳效用。所以今天，我们将剖析应对机制的心理学。我们将讨论我们遇到的不同类别的应对技巧和应对机制，从情绪导向到问题导向，再到适应性与非适应性。你知道，情况是这样的，并非所有的应对机制都是生而平等的。有大量的行为可能会让我们在当下感觉更好，但从长远来看却极其有害。酒精就是一个很好的例子。你知道，是的，它自然地降低了我们的焦虑水平，如果这真的是我们唯一关心的事，那么，
that's great, but it can also create dependency and addiction. And the same goes for a lot of avoiding coping mechanisms, ignoring the bad situation, just trying to minimize the emotional reaction that we are having rather than actively making our circumstances better or actively trying to improve our mood and improve what's going on around us. I also want to briefly discuss defense mechanisms. I feel like they come up a lot, but there is actually a huge difference between coping mechanisms and defense mechanisms. And finally, the ways that we can really tap into our subconscious to get to the bottom of what's bothering us and really find a way through. So that was a bit of a ramble.
那确实很棒，但它也会产生依赖和成瘾。许多逃避型应对机制也是如此，忽视糟糕的情况，仅仅试图将我们产生的情绪反应最小化，而不是积极地改善我们的环境，或者积极地尝试改善我们的情绪以及改善我们周围正在发生的事情。我还想简短讨论一下防御机制。我觉得它们经常被提及，但实际上应对机制和防御机制之间有着巨大的区别。最后，我们可以通过哪些方式真正深入潜 subconscious（潜意识）来找出困扰我们的根源并真正找到解决方法。刚才有点扯远了。
Enough of that. Without further ado, let's talk about the psychology behind our coping mechanisms and how we can make the most out of them. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange
废话少说。话不多说，让我们来谈谈应对机制背后的心理学，以及我们如何能够充分利用它们。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾真的相信籽油本质上有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”%，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out. on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回首往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point,
并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅是因为快克。我随时准备谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，
this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。艾滋病现在也摆在桌面上。谢谢你补充完那句话。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。欢迎来到我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们却仍在追逐它。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glare. inconsistencies in her story.
而且这是两个不同的信任级别。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《知难而进》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你在这项特定的测试中作假了两次，对吗？我作假了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So let's start super simple and from the beginning. What is coping? What are coping mechanisms? Coping is not just about getting over something and moving on, because by definition, coping is not a passive process. It is an active choice around integrating and recognizing an experience fully, sitting with it and finding a way forward.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。所以让我们从非常简单和最开始的地方讲起。什么是应对？什么是应对机制？应对不仅仅是摆脱某事然后继续前进，因为按定义，应对并不是一个被动的过程。它是关于充分整合和认识一段经历、与之共处并寻找前进道路的主动选择。
It is not pushing it to the sidelines. It's not hoping that it will go away. It is being the person who takes things by the reins and moves through them as hard as they may be. And coping behaviours, coping mechanisms are the tools that we use in that kind of journey, in that battle. Coping behaviours are voluntary and conscious ways of managing stressful situations and events by responding to either our emotions about the problem or the problem itself. It is essentially any way that we choose to manage trauma, to manage stress, pain, anything emotionally unpleasant. And the word conscious and voluntary is super important to focus on here because it is
它不是把它推到一边。它不是寄希望于它会自行消失。它是做那个把事情掌握在自己手中并穿越它们的人，无论它们多么艰难。而应对行为、应对机制就是我们在那种旅程、那种战斗中使用的工具。应对行为是通过对我们对问题的看法或问题本身做出反应，来管理压力情境和事件的自愿和有意识的方法。它本质上是我们选择用来管理创伤、管理压力、痛苦、任何情感上令人不快的事情的任何方式。而“有意识的”和“自愿的”这两个词在这里超级重要，因为它是
what distinguishes our coping mechanisms from our defence mechanisms. So in contrast to the very active nature of coping mechanisms, defense mechanisms are unconscious and they occur beyond our level. of awareness, very deep in the mind. The idea behind them is that when something occurs that is anxiety inducing or upsetting or that our conscious mind just simply can't deal with, can't process, our unconscious mind switches into gear and employs a number of backup strategies so that we don't feel the full force of an emotion or a situation. So these defense mechanisms, they were first labeled by Freud, the grandfather of psychoanalytic psychology, but they were actually really articulated by his daughter, Anna.
区分我们的应对机制和防御机制的关键。因此，与应对机制的高度主动性相反，防御机制是无意识的，它们发生在我们的意识水平之外，在心灵的最深处。其背后的理念是，当发生引起焦虑的、令人沮丧的、或我们的意识根本无法处理、无法加工的事情时，我们的无意识心灵就会启动并采用许多备用策略，这样我们就不会感受到一种情绪或情况的全部冲击。因此，这些防御机制最初是由精神分析心理学的祖父弗洛伊德提出的，但实际上是由他的女儿安娜真正阐述的。
And Anna often gets left out of a lot of the conversations around the history of psychology and some of the main theories that have come up in the last 100 years, including this one. And she kind of took over like the baton from her father and expanded a lot of his work into what we know it is today. So you've probably heard of a few defense mechanisms in your lifetime even if you have like zero experience with therapy or psychology. Denial is a big one. Being unable to accept reality. That is actually a defense mechanism.
而在关于心理学历史的许多讨论以及过去一百年出现的许多主要理论（包括这一理论）中，安娜经常被遗漏。她有点像从她父亲手中接过接力棒，并将他的许多工作扩展成了我们今天所知道的模样。所以你可能在生活中听说过一些防御机制，即使你对治疗或心理学只有零经验。否认是一个很大的防御机制。无法接受现实。这其实就是一个防御机制。
Another one is repression or what we would call motivated for getting, pushing an unpleasant experience very way down subconsciously when we aren't prepared to deal with it. Let me think of a few others of my favorite projection, attributing our unwanted thoughts and feelings to another person. Like, you might not like them very much, but deep down in the hidden parts of your mind, you know that that's not an appropriate thing to feel or admit.
另一个是压抑，或者我们所说的动机性遗忘，当我们在心理上没有准备好应对时，将不愉快的经历深深地推到潜意识里。让我想想其他几个我最喜欢的，投射，将我们不需要的想法和感觉归咎于另一个人。比如，你可能不是很喜欢他们，但在你内心深处隐藏的部分，你知道这不是一种合适的感受或承认的方式。
So you end up believing that they don't like you as a way to protect yourself and your unacceptable desires. That's projection. Regression is another one. Revert, you know, reverting back to a less mature version of yourself to deal with a situation that is really, distressing. So those are defense mechanisms. The reason that we want to prioritize coping mechanisms and why they always come out on top here is because they are something that we can control,
所以你最终会相信他们不喜欢你，以此来保护你自己和你不可接受的欲望。这就是投射。退行是另一个。退回到一个不那么成熟的自己，来应对一个非常痛苦的情况。所以这些就是防御机制。我们想要优先考虑应对机制的原因，以及为什么它们在这里总是拔得头筹，是因为它们是我们能够控制的东西，
whereas our defense mechanisms are something that we can't. They are, you know, stemming from our subconscious, which means that they are automatic. They're often controlled by impulse, by ego, by trauma. And so not entirely beneficial in these circumstances. even if we feel like they're protecting us, even if they are still managing or reducing our stress, defense mechanisms kind of take us out from behind the wheel and put us in the passenger seat. Coping mechanisms make us the driver. So coping mechanisms is where it's at. And you probably know quite a few.
而我们的防御机制是我们无法控制的。它们源自我们的潜意识，这意味着它们是自动的。它们通常由冲动、自我、创伤控制。所以在这些情况下并不完全有利。即使我们觉得它们在保护我们，即使它们仍在管理或减轻我们的压力，防御机制有点像是把我们从方向盘后拉开，把我们放在乘客座位上。而应对机制让我们成为司机。所以应对机制才是王道。你大概也知道不少。
These are things typically like meditation, exercise, nature walks, practicing gratitude, journaling, processing your emotions with a friend. and humor making light of a situation, planning, rationalizing a problem, but then also things like numbing yourself, isolating yourself, binge eating, binge drinking, risk taking. All of these behaviors, the good and the bad, they have an important component. Their performance serves some secondary mental purpose. For example, you might take major risks. to achieve a high that makes the bad feelings feel less sharp.
这些通常是诸如冥想、锻炼、自然漫步、练习感恩、写日记、与朋友处理你的情绪以及幽默——对情况轻描淡写、计划、将问题合理化，但同时也包括麻痹自己、孤立自己、暴饮暴食、酗酒、冒险等事情。所有这些行为，好的和坏的，都有一个重要的组成部分。它们的表现服务于某种次要的心理目的。例如，你可能会冒巨大的险，
You journal, not just because you like the look of, you know, the words on the page, but because there is some emotional clarity achieved through this practice, some kind of peace that you are able to voluntarily bring to yourself without waiting for the situation to change. So our pattern of coping mechanisms, that huge list that we just spoke about, they often become quite entrenched and they form a habit, meaning that when something really stressful happens in our lives, we tend to respond to those situations in the same way every single time
来获得一种快感，让不好的感觉不那么尖锐。你写日记，不仅是因为你喜欢页面上文字的样子，还因为通过这种实践获得了一些情感上的清晰，某种你能够自愿带给自己而无需等待情况改变的平静。所以我们的应对机制模式，我们刚刚谈到的那个庞大名单，它们经常变得根深蒂固并形成习惯，这意味着当我们的生活中发生真正压力重大的事情时，我们往往每次都以完全相同的方式对这些情况做出反应，
because we kind of know what works. We know what makes us feel better. Of course, there's a catch. We think we know what makes us feel better. Sometimes these coping mechanisms that we're using, whether that is exercising, journaling, binge drinking, It's what we learn from our parents. Other times, it's just an emotional reflex.
因为我们差不多知道什么管用。我们知道是什么让我们感觉更好。当然，这里有个抓马（问题）。我们以为自己知道什么能让我们感觉更好。有时我们正在使用的这些应对机制，无论是锻炼、写日记还是酗酒，都是我们从父母那里学来的。其他时候，它只是一种情感反射。
We responded to a really awful situation once in some kind of way. We responded by talking it out with a friend or we responded by going off and speeding around in our car and it kind of worked. So we learned the association between the behavior, the coping mechanism, and feeling better. And so now that's what we rely on. It's kind of like the analogy I always give is going back to the same mechanic for your car, even if you might be able to get a better price or service elsewhere, because it's just like what you trust and what you know.
我们曾经以某种方式对一次非常糟糕的情况做出过反应。我们的反应是跟朋友倾诉，或者我们的反应是开车出去狂飙，结果还挺管用。于是我们了解了行为、应对机制和感觉更好之间的联系。所以现在这就是我们所依赖的。这有点像我常给的比喻：即使你在别处可能以更低的价格或更好的服务修车，你还是会去找同一个修理工，因为那就是你信任和了解的。
And it kind of gets the job done. Even if you know that, you know, there might be a better mechanic who could give you a better price or who could fix your car faster, a better coping mechanism, you become kind of entrapped in what you know and what you've always relied on. For example, I have a really good friend who every time she's frustrated, every time she has to work late, every time she is annoyed at her family, she will switch off her phone and she'll go for a run and it really helps her. It's super effective. But it doesn't work in every circumstance, right? Like if you're on a plane or if you're injured, that's why we need a toolkit of coping mechanisms. We can't just rely on one and the only one that we come back to every time that makes us feel better. For me, you know, I really like like to sit and intellectualize my problems. I don't think that's a surprise. I literally have a psychology podcast where I break down every single thought I ever have. But sometimes, you know, for me, a feeling can't be rationalized. It just needs to be felt, which is why we need a toolkit,
而且它差不多能把事情办妥。即便你知道，可能有一个更好的修理工能给你更便宜的价格或者能更快地修好你的车——也就是一个更好的应对机制，你也会陷入你所熟知和一直依赖的事物中。例如，我有一个很好的朋友，每次她感到沮丧，每次她不得不加班，每次她对家人感到恼火时，她就会关掉手机去跑步，这真的对她很有帮助。这超级有效。但这并不适用于所有情况，对吧？比如如果你在飞机上或者如果你受伤了，这就是为什么我们需要一个应对机制工具箱。我们不能只依赖一种，而且每次都只能依赖那唯一一个让我们感觉更好的方法。对我自己来说，我真的喜欢坐下来把我的问题理论化。我想这并不让人意外。我literally（简直）有一个心理学播客，我在上面剖析我曾有过的每一个想法。但有时，对我来说，一种感觉是无法被合理化的。它只能去感受，这就是为什么我们需要一个工具箱，
which is why we need multiple coping mechanisms. So regardless of what habits have formed, these all kind of create a coping style. And there are four different. ways that we cope, four different categories that all of these behaviors fall into. So the first one is problem-focused coping. So this addresses the problem causing the distress by planning out a solution or waiting till it's an appropriate time to act. Looking at the problem and kind of realizing that if the problem goes away, if we can find a way to work around it, our stress, our distress, our grief will go away as well. That's problem
这就是为什么我们需要多种应对机制。因此，不管形成了什么习惯，这些最终都构成了某种应对风格。并且有四种不同的，
focus, the first category. Then we have emotion focused coping. This basically aims to cope by just reducing the negative emotions associated with the problem. You might not actually do anything about the problem. It's just kind of treating how you feel about it. So reframing the situation is something positive. Acceptance. Turning to humor. turning to spirituality or of course suppressing it. Then we have meaning-focused coping, which kind of falls into emotion-focused coping. So under emotion-focused coping, there is meaning-focused and social coping. So meaning-focused is when you and I might use cognitive strategies or some kind of part of our belief
应对方式，所有这些行为都归入这四种不同的类别。所以第一种是问题导向型应对。这通过规划解决方案或等到适当的时机采取行动来解决导致痛苦的问题。审视问题并意识到，如果问题消失了，如果我们能找到绕过它的方法，我们的压力、痛苦、悲伤也会随之消失。这就是问题导向，第一个类别。然后我们有情绪导向型应对。这基本上旨在通过减少与问题相关的消极情绪来应对。你实际上可能对问题本身什么都不做。它只是在处理你对它的感受。所以把情况重新构架为积极的事情。接受。转向幽默。转向精神信仰，或者当然是压抑它。然后我们有意义导向型应对，它有点属于情绪导向型应对。所以在情绪导向型应对下，有意义导向和社交导向。所以意义导向是指你和我可能会使用认知策略或我们信仰系统的某个部分，
system to make it seem like this situation has some kind of higher meaning to it. So if you hear people say, you know, everything happens for a reason or rejection is just redirection in response to something really awful or unfortunate happening, that is them applying a meaning-focused coping style. And it's their way of pushing through the situation by once again applying some kind of higher belief or higher reasoning to why they're going through that. It makes it like a little bit easier to swallow. And finally, we have a social coping, also known as support seeking, where, you know, we reduce our stress by seeking out the support of friends or family or seeking out others around
使这种情况看起来对我们有一定的更高意义。所以如果你听到人们说，你知道，一切发生都是有原因的，或者拒绝只是重定向——针对发生的非常糟糕或不幸的事情，这就是他们应用意义导向的应对风格。这是他们通过再次应用某种更高的信仰或更高的推理来解释他们为什么要经历这一切，从而度过难关的方式。这让事情变得更容易接受一点。最后，我们有社交导向，也称为寻求支持，即我们通过寻求朋友或家人的支持或寻求周围其他人的支持来减轻压力，让我们感觉更好。所以最好的应对风格，虽然这不是一场比赛，但它确实有点像，最好的那个——每次都能得金牌的那个，
us to make us feel better. So the best coping style, not that it's a competition, but it kind of is, the best of the more, the one that gets the gold star every single time, is actually a combination. It is a coping style that incorporates all dimensions of those four different categories. It's problem-focused, emotion-focused, meaning-focused, and we can always pull out social coping if we need it. And it's kind of like a healthy diet. You know, you can't just eat one food group. You can't just really rely on social coping or meaning-focused coping and expect to have the proper nutrition the proper skills. So there's been some really interesting studies recently that I've actually suggested that, you know, having a combination of all of these different types of coping is best, but also
实际上是一个组合。它是一种融合了这四种不同类别所有维度的应对风格。它是问题导向的、情绪导向的、意义导向的，并且在我们需要时，我们总是可以拿出社交导向。这就好比健康的饮食。你知道，你不能只吃一种食物。你不能只真正依赖社交导向或意义导向的应对，并期望获得适当的营养和技能。所以最近有一些非常有趣的的研究实际上表明，你知道，拥有所有这些不同类型应对的组合是最好的，但同时，
problem-focused coping strategies need to make up the majority. And the reason why is because problem-focused coping mechanisms are what gives us a sense of control over the problem. They are what show us that we have agency, that we can change the outcome of a situation, whereas meaning-focused coping, social coping, emotional coping, they all kind of say, you know, bad things just happen to us and we have to find a way to deal with them, rather than we have some level of control over our circumstances. So, of course, there are certain things that we just, you know, death is one of them, failure is another, they do just happen. And sometimes we do have to be reactive to that and find a way to pull through.
问题导向的应对策略需要占大部分。原因在于，问题导向的应对机制赋予了我们对问题的掌控感。它们向我们展示了我们具有能动性，我们能够改变局面的结果，而意义导向的应对、社交导向、情绪导向，它们都在某种程度上说，你知道，不好的事情就是会发生在我们身上，我们必须找到应对的方法，而不是说我们对自己的处境有一定的控制权。所以，当然，有些事情我们就是——死亡是其中之一，失败是另一个，它们确实会发生。有时我们确实必须对此做出反应并找到挺过去的方法。
But the reason problem-focused coping is so important is because the rest of those things that occur, you know, all these other circumstances that might happen, failure actually being one of them, right? You fail a test, you fail your driving test, I don't know, you fail an exam, you go through a breakup, whatever it is. There is only so much that dealing with the emotion can help you before you have to think about how you can move on and what kind of strategies you can put in place. Before that happens, the stress is always going to remain in some form and it might return because the other thing that links emotion, social and meaning-based coping is that they are
但问题导向应对之所以如此重要，是因为其余发生的事情（你知道，所有这些可能发生的其他情况，失败其实就是其中之一，对吧？你考试挂科了，你驾考没过，我不知道，你期末考砸了，你经历了分手，无论是什么）。在不得不考虑如何继续前进以及可以制定什么样的策略之前，仅靠处理情绪所能提供的帮助是有限的。在此之前，压力将始终以某种形式存在，并且它可能会卷土重来，因为连接情绪、社交和意义导向应对的另一件事是，它们是
reactive versus proactive. So what does that mean exactly? Well, coping, like I said, it isn't just about making ourselves feel better in response to an event that is part of it. You know, you really can't do anything if you were paralyzed by fear, regret, pain, stress, so you have to kind of move past that first. But the next level up from that is also doing a favor for our future selves and doing what we can to prevent that situation from happening again, whatever it may be. That is why problem focused coping is known as proactive because it is also protective. So, for example, if you keep getting into fights with your partner and it's extremely distressing and the only way that you can push through it is by, you know, going and having
被动反应的，而不是主动预防的。那么这到底是什么意思呢？好吧，就像我说的，应对不仅仅是让我们在应对一个事件时感觉更好——这只是其中的一部分。你知道，如果你被恐惧、遗憾、痛苦、压力所麻痹，你真的什么也做不了，所以你必须先走过那一关。但比这高一个层次的，也是在为未来的自己做一件好事，尽我们所能防止这种情况再次发生，无论它可能是什么。这就是为什么问题导向的应对被称为主动的，因为它也是保护性的。所以，例如，如果你不断与伴侣争吵，这极其痛苦，而你能度过难关的唯一方法就是去找你的朋友疯狂抱怨一番（你知道，涉及社交导向），然后你继续生活，你注定会继续争吵。你注定会继续经历那个循环。但如果你这样回应：是的，首先，当然是寻求一些，
like a huge rant about it to your friends, you know, involving social coping and then you move on, you are kind of bound to keep having that fight. You are bound to keep going through that cycle. But if you respond by, yeah, firstly, of course, seeking some. support but then also going to counseling or setting boundaries for yourself or taking a step back when you are arguing and realizing it's not working. You're also developing and evolving rather than just making yourself feel better. And I think that's something that I've realized the older that I've gotten. It's not just about, you know, it's not just about always giving myself the benefit of the doubt.
支持，但随后也去接受咨询，或者为自己设定界限，或者在你争吵时退一步并意识到这不管用。你同时也在发展和进化，而不仅仅是让自己感觉更好。我想随着年龄的增长，我意识到这就是这样。这不仅仅是关于，你知道，这不仅仅是关于总是给自己留有余地。
It's not just about always soothing hard things. It's also about. doing things that are going to make my life better in the long term. My future self is just as important in that situation as my current feelings. And I think that that is a perfect kind of segue into talking about another very important distinction, the crucial difference between adaptive coping mechanisms versus maladaptive coping mechanisms. Why is it that sometimes we choose coping mechanisms that are actually self-destructive that actually hurt us more? Like, you know, going and speaking to a friend every time we get into a fight rather than actually trying to improve our relationship. It feels very instinctual. It feels very meaningful, perhaps, in the moment. But why is it that we find
这不仅仅是关于总是去安抚困难的事情。这也是关于做那些从长远来看会让我的生活变得更好的事情。在那种情况下，未来的我和我当前的感觉同样重要。我认为这是一个完美的过渡，可以用来谈论另一个非常重要的区别，即适应性应对机制与非适应性应对机制之间的关键区别。为什么有时我们会选择那些实际上具有自我毁灭性、实际上对我们伤害更大的应对机制？比如，每次我们吵架时都去找朋友倾诉，而不是真正试图改善我们的关系。这感觉非常本能。在当下，它感觉非常意味深长，也许吧。但为什么我们会发现
ourselves in these cycles of not actually wanting to perhaps improve our circumstances or not even knowing how to do it? So we're going to talk about that after this short break. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are
自己陷入这些甚至可能不想改善现状、甚至不知道该如何改善的循环中呢？所以我们在短暂的休息之后会讨论这个问题。请继续关注。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾真的相信籽油本质上有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是
freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What? The hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》——数字“2”%，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。什么？乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回首往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅是因为快克。我随时准备谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。艾滋病现在也摆在桌面上。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
谢谢你补充完那句话。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。欢迎来到我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们却仍在追逐它。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free, I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。而且这是两个不同的信任级别。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《知难而进》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的I Heart Radio应用程序。搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你在这项特定的测试中作假了两次，等等，对吗？我作假了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·纳拉尼尼。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When something really awful happens or even something frustrating or overwhelming, sometimes all we want to do is distract ourselves and ignore it entirely. We want to completely disengage. That is an example of a maladaptive coping mechanism. Like I said before, right at the very beginning,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。当真正糟糕的事情发生，甚至只是令人沮丧或不知所措的事情发生时，有时我们唯一想做的事情就是分散自己的注意力并完全忽略它。我们想要完全抽离。这就是非适应性应对机制的一个例子。就像我之前说的，就在最开始的时候，
not all ways of coping are created equally. Some actually end up doing more harm than good, avoidance as an example. Even if in the moment they serve the primary purpose of making us feel a tad better, sometimes they actually make this situation worse or they make our emotional response to a situation worse in the long term. So that is where the distinction between an adaptive versus maladaptive coping mechanism comes into play. Adaptive coping mechanisms are positive. They help us evolve. They help us grow from a situation, even if it's baby steps. They are what we want. Maladaptive coping mechanisms, they're quite shallow. And they work in the short term, but they do so by hiding the
并不是所有的应对方式都是生而平等的。有些最终弊大于利，比如逃避。即使在当下，它们起到了让我们感觉稍微好一点的主要目的，但有时它们实际上会让情况变得更糟，或者从长远来看，让我们对情况的情绪反应变得更糟。因此，适应性与非适应性应对机制之间的区别就在这里发挥作用了。适应性应对机制是积极的。它们帮助我们进化。它们帮助我们从一种情况中成长，哪怕只是婴儿学步般的微小步伐。这就是我们想要的。非适应性应对机制则相当浅薄。它们在短期内起作用，但它们是通过隐藏来起作用的。
problem from us. They hide the situation from us by getting us to just focus on dealing with what we're feeling. They also often have negative consequences. Actually, that's a huge factor. They always do. That's what makes them maladaptive. And like I said, they're emotion-based, not problem-based. Let me give you some examples of what I mean here. So I spoke about this before, but binge drinking is a huge one and definitely a huge noteworthy one because amongst 20 year olds, 20-something-year-olds, amongst people in this decade, alcohol is just so widely accepted and excessive drinking is so tolerated that sometimes we don't even realize that we are using alcohol or some other substance to numb our pain as dramatic as that sounds. Alcohol is naturally a depressant, which means
我们无法解决。它们通过让我们专注于处理自己的感受，来向我们隐瞒情况。它们通常也会带来负面后果。实际上，这是一个巨大的因素。它们总是这样。这就是它们适应不良的原因。正如我所说，它们是基于情绪的，而不是基于问题的。让我举几个我所说意思的例子。我之前谈过这个，但酗酒是一个非常大的问题，绝对是一个值得注意的巨大问题，因为在20多岁的人当中，在这个年龄段的人当中，酒精是如此被广泛接受，过度饮酒是如此被容忍，以至于有时我们甚至没有意识到我们在用酒精或其他物质来麻痹我们的痛苦，尽管听起来很戏剧化。酒精本质上是一种抑制剂，这意味着
that it slows down how messages travel through our body, including. anxious messages. And so initially when something really terrible happens, having like half a bottle of wine is going to make you feel more relaxed. It's going to make you feel better. It's a lot harder to focus on our worries when, you know, we're a bit tipsy or we're drunk. And in that way, the negative feelings are eliminated. In my own experience, the times I have, you know, drunk the most to be a bit vulnerable with you guys, have been when I've been in the most emotional pain. At the end of a relationship, when I first moved to a new city and I knew no one and I was really, really lonely. And any kind of substance that numbs us or artificially induces, you know,
它会减慢信息在身体中传播的速度，包括焦虑的信息。因此，最初当非常糟糕的事情发生时，喝上半瓶葡萄酒会让你感到更放松。它会让你感觉更好。当我们有点微醺或喝醉时，很难专注于我们的担忧。通过这种方式，负面情绪被消除了。以我自己的经历为例，为了对你们坦诚一点，我喝得最多的时候，正是我处于最痛苦的情感之中的时候。在一段感情结束时，当我刚搬到一个新城市，谁也不认识，而且感到非常非常孤独的时候。任何麻痹我们或人为诱导的物质，
a lot of happy feelings that kind of mask the real problem is a form of maladaptive coping. because it is keeping you attached to the idea that if you feel better, you are moving forward. So speaking of alcohol consumption, let's also talk about food as well. Emotional eating is another maladaptive coping mechanism. So I did do an entire episode on this last year. It's episode 135 if you want to listen to it. And it really goes into this a lot more. But sometimes, not always, but sometimes we eat as a way of regular.
许多能够掩盖真实问题的快乐感觉，其实是一种适应不良的应对方式。因为它让你执着于这样一种观念：只要你感觉好一点，你就是在向前迈进。说到酒精消耗，我们来谈谈食物。情绪性进食是另一种适应不良的应对机制。去年我针对这个话题做过一整期节目。如果你想听的话，那是第135期。它更深入地探讨了这一点。但有时，并非总是如此，但有时我们吃东西是为了调节情绪。
our emotions rather than from a place of actual hunger. Like food is a form and a source of comfort. Food is warm. Food is filling. And it also elicits feelings of control, feelings of fullness where emotional fullness perhaps isn't possible. Underneath it all, though the emotions remain the same, it is once again a band-aid.
我们的情绪，而不是出于真正的饥饿感。食物是一种安慰的形式和来源。食物是温暖的。食物是饱腹的。它还能带来掌控感，在情感无法得到满足时带来饱腹感。然而，在这一切之下，情绪保持不变，它再次只是一块创可贴。
Another huge one, an honorable mention, I don't know, a dishonorable mention maybe, but a huge one for our for our 20s is isolating ourselves and withdrawing. Often we don't even realize that we're doing this. We think that we are helping ourselves. We think that we are helping those around us. We think that we are giving ourselves space to process. But we are actually reducing the social resources that we have available to us,
另一个重要的问题，值得一提——我不知道，也许是不值得一提，但对于我们20多岁的人来说，这是一个极其普遍的问题——那就是孤立自己和退缩。通常我们甚至没有意识到自己在这样做。我们以为我们在帮助自己。我们以为我们在帮助身边的人。我们以为我们在给自己留出空间去消化。但实际上，我们正在减少可用的社会资源，
those social touch points that help so much. You know, what if we actually unconsciously as well, like with withdrawal are punishing ourselves because we're, We don't feel like it should be somebody else's problem, or we don't feel like we deserve empathy or we deserve support. There was this paper published in 2001 that I read when I was researching this episode, and it spoke about how isolation is often a self-induced coping mechanism to deal with excessive worry and to avoid human interaction. We hermit. Obviously, that is not always the case, right?
那些给予巨大帮助的社会触点。你知道，我们是否也在潜意识中，就像通过退缩来惩罚自己一样，因为我们觉得这不应该成为别人的麻烦，或者我们觉得我们不值得得到同情或支持。我读过2001年发表的一篇论文，当时我在为这期节目做研究，它谈到孤立通常是一种自我诱导的应对机制，用来应对过度的担忧并避免人际交往。我们像寄居蟹一样把自己藏起来。很明显，情况并非总是如此，对吗？
sometimes the fact that we don't have social support is what causes us to use other maladaptive coping mechanisms. But sometimes as well, withdrawing from a social support system or from friends and family and who are available is a way of coping that we don't realize we're doing. And it's kind of no surprise to me that this mechanism, it often does co-occur with things like depression or social anxiety where there is already a tendency within these conditions towards withdrawal. Escapism, that is another maladaptive coping mechanism. Finding comfort in a reality or a fantasy that is detached from your own. Like binge watching endless hours of TV or escapism through daydreaming, putting up this wall
有时，缺乏社会支持正是导致我们使用其他适应不良的应对机制的原因。但有时，从社会支持系统或可用的朋友和家人身边退缩，也是一种我们没有意识到自己在采用的应对方式。这种机制经常与抑郁症或社交焦虑等情况共同出现，这对我来说并不奇怪，因为这些情况本身就具有退缩的倾向。逃避，这是另一种适应不良的应对机制。在脱离现实的现实或幻想中寻找安慰。比如连续看几个小时的电视，或者通过白日梦来逃避，筑起这道墙
between you and reality, you and the situation that you're dealing with through a form of really emotionally consuming distraction. And this really links to the last example I'll give today because, you know, the list could definitely go on. But this is the example I gave at the beginning, which is avoidance, outright ignoring the problem. Now, this might sound a lot like denial, which we know as a defense mechanism because it's, you know, it's similar, right? It's pretending the problem doesn't exist, but actually with avoidance, it's a conscious choice to look away. You kind of know that the situation is happening. You know that if you were to seriously deal with it, it would be really painful or tricky or stressful.
通过一种真正消耗情绪的分散注意力的方式，在你与现实、你所处理的状况之间建立起联系。这确实与我今天要给出的最后一个例子联系在一起，因为，你知道，这个例子肯定可以继续列下去。但这正是我在开始时给出的例子，那就是回避，彻底忽视问题。现在，这听起来可能很像否认，我们知道这是一种防御机制，因为它们很相似，对吧？它假装问题不存在，但实际上回避是一种有意识的视而不见。你有点知道情况正在发生。你知道如果你认真处理它，它会非常痛苦、棘手或充满压力。
Denial is not even realizing that there is a problem. You know, you're choosing to postpone or choosing to avoid or evade a problem with avoidance. Denial, you're just completely, blissfully unaware that it's even happening. So if coping mechanisms are voluntary and we know these behaviours keep leading us back to the same or even a darker place, why do we do it? Why do we use poor forms of coping? There is not one answer for you. My answer is that it's complicated, but I will offer you a few explanations. The first and most simple explanation is that maladaptive coping mechanisms are sometimes just more accessible.
否认甚至没有意识到问题的存在。你知道，通过回避，你选择推迟、避免或逃避问题。而在否认中，你只是完全、幸福地对正在发生的事情一无所知。因此，如果应对机制是自愿的，并且我们知道这些行为不断把我们带回原点甚至更黑暗的地方，我们为什么要这样做？我们为什么要使用糟糕的应对方式？这没有一个单一的答案。我的答案是情况很复杂，但我会提供一些解释。第一个也是最简单的解释是，适应不良的应对机制有时更容易获得。
They are easier for relieving the immediate discomfort. it whereas adaptive coping mechanisms sometimes require, you know, it's a hard reality, they require a bit of an investment, they kind of take longer to help. If you've just gotten broken up with or you've just lost out on an really, you know, amazing opportunity, you've just had a fight, you've gotten your hopes up and you've been let down, you know, a couple glasses of wine and trying not to think about it is going to immediately make you feel better. But, you know, meditating, for example, probably isn't going to make you feel better if it's your first time ever doing it. You know, meditation is amazing. I do actually really promote it, but the thing is
它们更容易用来缓解即时的不适。然而，适应不良的应对机制有时需要——这是一个残酷的现实——它们需要一点投入，它们需要更长的时间来发挥作用。如果你刚分手，或者你刚失去了一个非常、你知道的、绝佳的机会，你刚吵过架，你抱有希望却又失望，你知道，几杯酒下肚，尽量不去想它，会立即让你感觉好一些。但是，你知道，冥想，举个例子，如果这是你第一次这样做，可能不会让你感觉更好。你知道，冥想太棒了。我实际上确实很推广它，但问题是
that it's a practice, right? It's a skill that builds over time, whereas anyone over the age of 18 in Australia or, you know, 20, 21 elsewhere can go and use alcohol or abuse alcohol or rely on alcohol and it's a much quicker fix. Secondly, sometimes maladaptive coping mechanisms do act as a form of self-sabotage. So if you have poor self-esteem, a lot of self-doubt, imposter syndrome, maybe as well, when bad things happen, it's hard to not see those as coming down to something wrong with you or some character fault. You see yourself as a failure or as a loser or is not deserving of love. and why would someone like that deserve to be taken care of or deserve to not be in pain or deserve to invest in healthy coping mechanisms if at the end of the day they are a bad person
它是一种练习，对吧？它是一项随着时间积累的技能，而在澳大利亚，任何18岁以上的人，或者在其他地方20、21岁的人，都可以去使用酒精或滥用酒精，或者依赖酒精，这是一个快得多的解决方法。其次，有时适应不良的应对机制确实起到了自我破坏的形式。因此，如果你自尊心低、充满自我怀疑、有冒名顶替综合症，可能也是这样，当坏事发生时，很难不把这些归咎于你自身的某种问题或性格缺陷。你觉得自己是个失败者、是个卢瑟，或者不值得被爱。为什么这样的人配得上被照顾，配得上不经历痛苦，或者配得上投资于健康的应对机制，如果归根结底他们是一个坏人
or they are a lost cause? It all comes down to, I think, sometimes self-esteem and what we believe that we should be providing with ourselves. It's interesting because in this case, you know, firstly those false beliefs are entirely untrue. Let's get that clear. But secondly, those beliefs are subconscious, but the actions derived from those feelings are conscious. So it's like this weird mix of defense and coping mechanisms, if that makes sense. Our motivations are subconscious, but our behavior is conscious and it is in response to a feeling that we just can't quite identify, right? We are
或者他们无可救药？这一切有时都归结为自尊，以及我们认为自己应该为自己提供什么。有趣的是，在这种情况下，你知道，首先那些错误的信念完全是不真实的。让我们把这一点弄清楚。但其次，这些信念是潜意识的，但由这些感觉衍生的行为是有意识的。所以这有点像防御机制和应对机制的奇怪组合，如果这说得通的话。我们的动机是潜意识的，但我们的行为是有意识的，它是对一种我们无法完全识别的感觉的回应，对吧？我们在
numbing ourselves. We are withdrawing as a conscious way of dealing with our emotions because perhaps underneath it all, we don't feel like we deserve to offer ourselves something better and we are self-sabotaging. Generational trauma and learning comes into this conversation in a major way. Coping strategies begin in early childhood and they begin through not just our own psychological and physical responses to stress and testing what works, but also by what we see our parents doing. when we see our parents engaging in dysfunctional strategies like avoidance, like numbing themselves with alcohol or food or some other substance or activity, not only do we observe and mimic that,
麻痹自己。我们退缩作为处理情绪的有意识方式，因为也许在这一切之下，我们觉得我们不配为自己提供更好的东西，我们在自我破坏。代际创伤和学习在这场对话中占据了重要地位。应对策略始于幼儿时期，它们不仅始于我们自己对压力的心理和生理反应以及测试什么有效，还始于我们看到父母的做法。当我们看到父母采取功能失调的策略时，比如回避、用酒精或食物或其他物质或活动来麻痹自己，我们不仅观察和模仿，
but it can also create a childhood environment in which we are not taught to accept and hold hard emotions or to work through them. We are not taught to be soft and tender and to turn to others for support, but to instead find a way to just feel better in the moment and eventually move on. So this is a form of emotional invalidation. And when you are told that your emotions, especially as a child, were not reasonable, they weren't rational, they weren't valid, you're too sensitive, that becomes part of our habits and part of the suppression,
而且它还会创造一个童年环境，在这个环境中，我们没有被教导去接受和承受艰难的情绪，也没有被教导去度过难关。我们没有被教导要温柔、要向他人寻求支持，而是去寻找一种在当下感觉更好并最终继续前进的方法。所以这是一种情感否定。当被告知你的情绪，特别是在作为孩子的时候，是不合理的、不理性的、无效的，你太敏感了，这成为了我们习惯的一部分，也是压抑的一部分，
part of the maladaptive coping that we perform. I feel like this is quite obvious, but we see that a lot with men, people who are raised as boys and raised as men, whereby there is such a societal influence around them at all times to be quiet when it comes to their emotional problems. And so it's through that social conditioning that they learn how to use maladaptive coping mechanisms to help themselves. And we all know that doesn't work, right? It ends up in angry outbursts, it ends up in sabotaging relationships, it ends up in dysfunction.
我们所表现出的适应不良的应对方式。我觉得这很明显，但我们在男性身上看到很多这种情况，那些被当作男孩和男人抚养长大的人，在他们的周围总是存在着一种社会影响，要求他们在面对情感问题时保持安静。因此，正是通过这种社会化，他们学会了如何使用适应不良的应对机制来帮助自己。我们都知道这不管用，对吧？它最终会导致愤怒爆发，最终会导致破坏感情，最终会导致功能失调。
but a lot of the times it's not even like we had a choice. Nobody has set an example. The other main problem with a lot of these techniques, if we can call them that, they are techniques for managing emotions, is that they actually leave a lot of residual grief. They leave a lot of residual suffering, residual sadness, residual stress because we haven't been proactive about the situation, or we haven't actually fully processed and moved through the emotion,
但很多时候，这甚至不像我们有选择一样。没有人树立榜样。许多这些技巧的另一个主要问题（如果我们能这样称呼它们的话，它们是管理情绪的技巧）是它们确实留下了许多残余的悲伤。它们留下了许多残余的痛苦、残余的悲伤、残余的压力，因为我们对这种情况没有采取积极主动的态度，或者我们没有真正完全处理和度过这种情绪，
so it goes on to kind of hide and influence our behavior in other areas. You know, say you've gone through a really rough period at work. You do what you can to feel better. You cope, you suppress, you drink, you do whatever it is and you move on. The thing is you actually haven't found a way to make your work life better for you, if there even is a way. You haven't found a way to put in strategies. You haven't found a way to talk out your emotions or to process them.
所以它继续隐藏并影响我们在其他领域的行为。你知道，假设你经历了工作中最艰难的一段时期。你尽你所能让自己感觉更好。你应对，你压抑，你喝酒，你做任何事然后继续前进。问题是，你实际上并没有找到一种让你的工作生活对你来说更好的方法，如果真的有这种方法的话。你没有找到制定策略的方法。你没有找到说出你的情绪或处理它们的方法。
And so a lot of the time, and I remember this happening with, me when I worked as like a in a corporate job, I would get really, really stressed. I would just push it all down. I would, you know, keep busy. And I would notice that in the weeks and the days that followed, those bad feelings that I hadn't actually processed bled into my relationships. I would start fights with my boyfriend. I would ignore my friends. And the disruption of that event and that experience would remain. Again, it is not our fault. That is something I really want to impress on you all. you've just kind of picked up on the examples set for you by family, by peers, by society that, you know, really should have a 101 class on like, how do you actually cope with hard things in life?
所以很多时候，我记得当我做公司职员的时候，我也有过这样的经历，我会变得非常非常紧张。我会把这一切都压下去。我会，你知道，让自己保持忙碌。我会注意到在接下来的几周和几天里，那些我没有真正处理过的坏情绪蔓延到了我的关系中。我会开始和我的男友吵架。我会忽视我的朋友。那种事件和经历的破坏将依然存在。再说一次，这不是我们的责任。这是我真的很想向你们所有人强调的一点。你只是从家庭、同龄人、社会为你树立的榜样中体察到了这一点，你知道，本该有一门基础课程来教你：你究竟该如何应对生活中的艰难险阻？
We have never had the opportunity or perhaps even in the time to see what else is out there, to see how we could cope better. Because also sometimes, like, the feelings are just so intense. We just do what we have to do. You know, our lives are so busy that sometimes it's impossible to pull ourselves away and, you know, take a break or go on a nature walk or to journal out our feelings. Sometimes we just have to respond to what is happening. So one final explanation for an over-reliance on maladaptive coping mechanisms, especially the emotion-focused kind, comes down to a concept in psychology called
我们从来没有机会甚至没有时间去看看外面还有什么，去看看我们如何能更好地应对。因为有时，由于情绪实在太强烈了。我们只能做我们必须做的事。你知道，我们的生活太忙了，有时根本不可能让自己抽身出来，你知道，休息一下，去自然中散步，或者把我们的情绪写进日记里。有时我们只能对正在发生的事情做出反应。因此，对过度依赖适应不良的应对机制（尤其是以情绪为中心的应对机制）的最后一个解释，归结为心理学中的一个概念：
learned helplessness. If you've been handed a few sets of just really bad cards, you've just had some really bad luck recently. Firstly, you're probably feeling exhausted, but secondly, if your efforts to keep picking yourself back up and doing better and picking yourself back up and problem solving and picking yourself up and having a good attitude, if that just isn't working, you've probably adopted an idea that you just don't have the control that you would like.
习得性无助。如果你被发了一手烂牌，你最近运气真的很差。首先，你可能会感到筋疲力尽，但其次，如果你不断重新振作、做得更好、重新振作、解决问题、重新振作并保持良好态度的努力根本不管用，你可能已经接受了这样一种观念：你根本没有你想要的控制权。
You don't get a say in what's happening to you, and so you have adopted a position of learned helplessness. Sometimes we start to be quite global with that judgment, right? And we believe that the reason all these bad things keep happening is because we just have bad luck or bad karma or it's a bad period. And so we just endure it and we do what we can emotionally. And that means sometimes falling into bad habits with how we cope. So how do we break this pattern and move away from avoidant or,
你对发生在你身上的事情没有发言权，因此你采用了习得性无助的立场。有时我们开始对这种判断变得相当全面，对吧？我们相信所有这些坏事不断发生的原因只是因为我们运气不好、或者命不好、或者正处于一个糟糕的时期。所以我们只是忍受它，并在情感上尽我们所能。这意味着有时会在我们如何应对方面陷入坏习惯。那么我们如何打破这种模式，摆脱逃避或
maladaptive coping to approach orientated coping. How do we kind of stop, you know, sometimes making things worse for ourselves, even though our intentions are merely just to feel a little bit more at peace, a little bit less stressed. Let's talk about it. So there is this very well-known Carl Jung quote that I love and it says, until you make the unconscious conscious, it will direct your life and you will call it fate. And what I always interpret this quote, is saying is that our maladaptive coping skills have an origin. Until we work out what that is, we are basically destined to always see life in our circumstances as against us and to find ourselves in a bit of a toxic cycle.
从适应不良的应对方式转变为面向解决问题的应对方式。我们如何才能停止让事情变得更糟，尽管我们的初衷只是为了获得更多的平静、减少一点压力？我们来聊聊这个。卡尔·荣格有一句非常有名的名言我很喜欢，它是这样说的：“在你把无意识变得有意识之前，它将主导你的人生，而你称之为命运。”我一直对这句话的理解是，我们那些适应不良的应对技巧是有根源的。在我们弄清楚这个根源之前，我们基本上注定总是会把生活和处境看作是在与我们作对，并发现自己陷入了一种有点毒性的循环中。
That might be a harsh truth. That might be something that you don't really want to hear. I probably didn't want to hear it when I first did, but one of the only things we can control in this world is how we react. to what happens to us and how we, as much as we can, positively integrate that into our story and find a way to learn and grow from it. Like, it just kind of sucks sometimes because a lot of the time we didn't do the damage in the first place.
这可能是一个残酷的真相。这可能并不是你真正想听到的内容。当我第一次听到时，我可能也不想听，但在这个世界上我们能控制的唯一事情之一，就是我们如何对发生在我们身上的事情做出反应，以及我们如何尽最大努力将其积极地融入我们的故事中，并找到从中学习和成长的方法。有时候这真的很糟糕，因为很多时候一开始并不是我们造成的破坏。
The stress or the pain wasn't caused by us, but we do get to reclaim our power in response to it and coming back to our adaptive, positive ways of coping. So firstly, if you've become really reliant on maladaptive coping, you have to have do understand why that might be. Is it past trauma? Is it stress overload? Is it because you don't know any other way to cope? Is it the immediate relief? Is it the temporary control? Is it history? Getting clear on where it begins helps you find an alternative and practice those positive alternatives. It's really annoying and frustrating that adaptive coping mechanisms take a while to really take hold, but it's one of those things that really I think deserves an investment. I
压力或痛苦不是由我们引起的，但我们确实可以重新掌控自己来应对它，并回归到我们适应性、积极的应对方式上来。所以首先，如果你变得非常依赖适应不良的应对方式，你必须去理解为什么会这样。是因为过去的创伤吗？是因为压力过载吗？是因为你不知道还有什么其他方式可以应对吗？是为了即时的解脱吗？是为了暂时的控制感吗？是为了历史原因吗？弄清楚这一切是从哪里开始的，有助于你找到替代方案并练习这些积极的替代方案。适应机制需要一段时间才能真正发挥作用，这确实让人感到很烦恼和沮丧，但我认为这绝对是值得投入的事情。我
I saw this really interesting, I don't know if it was on like Twitter or I don't know, but somebody said this the other day I read it somewhere that was like, you can ruin your life in a second. What is something that you can do in that same amount of time that would drastically improve your life? And it is positive coping. If you've had a stressful day and you want to have just a huge rant to your friend or you want to have half a bottle of wine, try something else first. Try something more energetic or nourishing for you, nourishing for your soul, nourishing for your mental. health. Try something that your mind and your nervous system will thank you for later. Maybe some somatic healing. Have a dance around your house. Get the nervous energy out. Some movement. Take 10 minutes and do a brain dump. One of my favorite things to do is called progressive relaxation where you work from
我看到过一个非常有趣的内容，我不知道它是在推特上还是哪里，反正前几天我在某个地方读到过，大意是：你可以在一秒钟内毁掉你的人生。那么，有什么事情你可以在同样长的时间内做到，从而极大地改善你的人生呢？那就是积极的应对。如果你度过了充满压力的一天，想对朋友大发牢骚，或者想喝上半瓶葡萄酒，请先尝试点别的。尝试一些更有活力的事情，或者能滋养你、滋养你的灵魂、滋养你的心理健康的事情。尝试一些能让你的大脑和神经系统在事后向你表示感谢的事情。也许可以做一些躯体疗愈。在屋子里跳支舞。把神经系统的能量释放出来。做一些运动。花10分钟进行一次大脑倾倒。我最喜欢做的事情之一被称为渐进式放松，即从
your toes to your forehead, really tensing and then releasing your muscles. And notice, pay attention. Do you feel the stress lessen in your body? Do you feel less overwhelmed? Adopting more positive coping strategies is as much about relearning what your body and your mind responds to as it is unlearning previously counterproductive ways of dismissing or suppressing your heart emotions. Something that really helped me was coping statements as well and the list I love the most was created by these two psychologists back in 2015 and I love them because these statements have really helped me reshape the narrative in my head or the narrative that I used to have that any I did wouldn't help my circumstances, you know, that learned helplessness mindset. And the statements include things like, I'm going to face this challenge and handle it as best as I can, even if the outcome doesn't change. It might not work out 100%, but, you know, I'm going to give it my best and see what happens. I've been in this situation before and I've
你的脚趾到额头，真正地紧绷然后放松你的肌肉。然后去注意、去留意。你是否感觉到身体里的压力减轻了？你是否觉得没那么不知所措了？采用更多积极的应对策略，既是重新学习你的身体和大脑对什么有反应，同时也是抛弃以往那种没有成效、用于打发或压抑内心痛苦情绪的方式。真正对我有所帮助的还有应对陈述，我最喜欢的清单是由两位心理学家在2015年创建的，我非常喜欢它们，因为这些陈述确实帮助我重塑了我脑海中的叙事，或者说我曾经拥有的那种无论做什么都无法改变现状的习得性无助心态。这些陈述包括：我要直面这个挑战，并尽我所能去处理它，即使结果没有改变。事情可能不会百分之百顺利，但你知道的，我会竭尽全力看看会发生什么。我以前也遇到过这种情况，并且
survived. I am strong enough to handle this, whatever it is, that it happens. Things often aren't as bad as they first seem. Those are your coping statements. Hopefully you see why these would be helpful, right? It's not just about thinking positive thoughts or whatever, like that toxic positivity mindset, but being able to just acknowledge that, yes, this circumstance is sucky, this is shitty, this is annoying. I can't change that situation, but I am capable. I am the common denominator.
活了下来。我有足够的实力来应对这一切，无论发生什么。事情往往没有最初看起来那么糟糕。这些就是你的应对陈述。希望你能明白为什么这些会很有帮助，对吧？这不仅仅是关于进行积极的思考，或者诸如那种有毒的积极性心态，而是能够去承认：是的，这个处境很糟糕，真的很烂，很烦人。我无法改变那种情况，但我有能力。我是共同决定因素。
My actions are a big factor in pushing through and changing next week circumstances or changing how I respond. That kind of brings me to my next tip. Know yourself and know your stresses. If there is a situation, you know you struggle with and you will really have to rely on your coping mechanisms, perhaps more than normal, make yourself a list of what works. Make yourself a dictionary of coping.
我的行动是扭转和改变下周的处境或改变我如何反应的一个重要因素。这自然引出了我的下一个小建议。了解你自己，了解你的压力源。如果有一种情况是你深知自己很难应对的，并且你将不得不比平时更多地依赖你的应对机制，那么就给自己列一份行之有效的清单。给自己编一本应对字典。
And include in that list one thing from every bucket that we spoke about before. An emotion-focused way of coping, social-focused, meaning-focused, and problem-focused. it's like having four lines of defense. So for me, you know, I know that going on a plane is something that's really stressful. For others, it might be exam season. It might be seeing your family. For me, it is going on a plane.
并在那份清单中包含我们之前讨论过的每个类别中的一项。一种以情绪为中心的应对方式、以社交为中心的、以意义为中心的和以问题为中心的应对方式。这就好比拥有四道防线。所以对我和大家来说，你知道的，坐飞机是一件压力很大的事。对其他人来说，可能是考试季。可能是见你的家人。对个人而言，对我来说就是坐飞机。
And I have in my notes at all times a list of like 10 plus things I know will help me before, during and after a flight. I also have, you know, five statements that help me rationalize my feelings, five affirmations. I have my anxiety meditation downloaded. You know, the more productive, adaptive, positive coping skills you have in your artillery, the better it's going to be
我随时在备忘录里列着10多项我知道在飞行前、飞行中和飞行后能帮到我的事情。我还有5个能帮我理清思绪的陈述句，也就是5条肯定语。我下载了我的焦虑冥想音频。你知道的，你的武器库里有越多富有成效、适应性强的、积极的应对技巧，情况就会越好
because it's the security of having multiple things you can fall back on. I think at the end of the day, I'm going to say it again and you're probably like, okay, I get it. But, you know, coping isn't just about eliminating bad feelings because we know that feelings are not evil. They're not bad.
因为这是一种拥有多种可以回旋余地的安全感。我想归根结底，我要再说一遍，你可能会觉得“好吧，我明白了”。但是，你知道的，应对不仅仅是为了消除不好的感觉，因为我们知道感觉并不是邪恶的。它们并不坏。
They are just our body trying to communicate with us. coping is also not about always having an answer or a solution, it's about resilience. And the four biggest factors and contributors to resilience are wellness and taking care of yourself in the good times and the bad, healthy thinking, being realistic about your problems, not, you know, catastrophizing or doomsdaying, finding meaning and purpose, knowing that there is a deeper part of you that these hard times can't touch. And finally, connection, sharing, being more. vulnerable, having an open heart, even when it is really difficult to reach out. That makes us,
它们只是我们的身体试图与我们沟通的方式。应对也不是为了总能得到答案或解决方案，而是关乎韧性。而构成韧性的四大主要因素和贡献者是：健康并在顺境和逆境中照顾好自己；健康的思维，对你的问题保持现实的看法，而不是将灾难化或末日化；寻找意义和目的，知道你内心深处有一部分是这些艰难时光无法触及的；最后是连接、分享、更加敞开心扉、怀揣一颗开放的心，即使在很难向人求助的时候也是如此。这让我们，
you know, that kind of makes up part of our social focused coping skills. But I think if you want to be resilient, focus on what you can do when times are good, but also find a way to lean back on your positive relationships so that it doesn't feel like you're only doing so during a crisis and so that you avoid withdrawal and isolation because I think that always just makes things a hundred times worse, coping mechanisms at the end of the day, they are the umbrella in the storm, right? It's still going to be raining, but you're carrying something with you that you can pull out to protect yourself. You are changing how you react to a bad day at work, how you react to a fight with your partner, how you react to a bad mental health day, a bad mental health month.
你知道的，这构成了我们以社交为中心的应对技巧的一部分。但我认为，如果你想变得有韧性，就要关注在时光美好时你能做些什么，同时也要找到一种方式来依靠你积极的社会关系，这样就不会让你觉得只有在危机时刻才这么做，从而避免退缩和孤立，因为我认为那样总是会让事情变得糟糕成百上千倍。归根结底，应对机制就是暴风雨中的一把伞，对吧？雨依然会下，但你随身携带了一些可以拿出来保护自己的东西。你正在改变你对工作糟糕一天的反应，对与伴侣争吵的反应，对糟糕的心理健康日、糟糕的心理健康月的反应。
And it's not about ignoring it. It's not about letting it consume you. It's about having this relationship with your emotions whereby you're like, you are just a little ghost in my house. And yeah, I wish I could get rid of you, but maybe I won't. So let's find a way to move forward and integrate what I'm experiencing. So thank you so much for listening. If you have made it this far, I really enjoyed this episode. I feel like I needed a reminder on coping mechanisms. It might seem so basic, right? It might seem so boring. But for so many of us, when was the last time like you really sat down and thought about what skills you had to make hard things in your life a little bit easier. When were we ever taught that? It's just mind-blowing to me that I went to
这并不是要去忽视它。这不是让它吞噬你。这是要与你的情绪建立这样一种关系：你就像我家里的小幽灵，是的，我真希望摆脱你，但也许我不会。所以让我们找到一种方法继续前进，并将我正在经历的一切整合起来。非常感谢大家的收听。如果你听到了这里，我真的很享受这一期节目。我觉得自己需要对应对机制做一次温习。这看起来可能非常基础，对吧？可能看起来非常无聊。但对于我们很多人来说，上一次你真正坐下来思考自己拥有什么技能，能让生活中的难事变得稍微轻松一点，是什么时候？我们什么时候被教导过这些？我感到震惊的是，我上
school for so many years and nobody ever did a class on this. Nobody ever explained these things to me. So hopefully this is the education that you needed when it came to this topic. As always, if there is somebody who needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share a link. Send them a screenshot, whatever you would like. And if you enjoyed this episode, please leave a five-star review on Apple podcast, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now, it will take a couple seconds. And it really does help the show to grow. When you leave nice reviews, I read them all. So chances are, if you have already, I've read it and I've saved it into my little smile file. And I really appreciate it. And if you do have an episode suggestion, I say this at the end of every episode,
了那么多年的学，却从来没有人开过这方面的课。从来没有人向我解释过这些事情。所以希望这就是你在这个话题上所需要的教育。一如既往，如果有谁需要听听这期节目，请随时分享链接。发给他们一张截图，随你喜欢。如果你喜欢这期节目，请在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，这只需要花几秒钟时间，并且确实对节目的成长很有帮助。当你留下好评时，我都会阅读。所以如果你已经写了，很有可能我已经读过了，并把它存进了我的“微笑文档”里。我真的很感激。如果你对节目有什么建议，我每期节目的最后都会说，
hit me up on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. I would love to hear from you. And until next time, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle with yourself. Please, and we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
在Instagram上联系我@That Psychology Podcast。我很期待听到你们的声音。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。拜托了，我们很快会再聊。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hard. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts,
我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，
or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that
或任何你收听播客的地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
Trust your girlfriends Listen to the girlfriends Trust me babe On the Iheart radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcast On the look back at it podcast From 1979
相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，或任何你收听播客的地方。在《回溯过去》播客中。从1979年开始，
That was a big moment for me 84 is big to me I'm Sam J And I'm Alex English Each episode we pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends
对我来说那是个重大时刻。84对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何与朋友们一起度过难关的，
fellow comedians and favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
同为喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家，就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔在谈论80年代时所说的那样。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加梅斯主持的《艰难之道》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. how many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难之道》。这是一档iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是由真人制作的。本集暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。